uh doing his thing man Roy Woods is in
the building yes sir yes sir what's good
my brother welcome man uh how's it feel
to get on the road and sing these new
songs from amazing bro this album that
everybody was waiting for for so long
I've been I've been waiting to sing
these songs for so long you know so yeah
it feels good like me and the team me
and my engineer we go to rehearsals all
the time and we're like you know I've
been doing a lot of um the older songs
from Co cuz of and right so like but I
have the new songs the new songs are
building so I'm like damn I want to
perform these songs but so now that I
get to and I've seen the reaction and
what the fans like like I'm just like
all right wow you guys really like the
new you know what I'm saying this new
[__] so yeah it feels amazing dog how
many dates in are you man uh we're
halfway in yeah we're halfway in the
tour yeah so now we just got to do with
the East Coast yeah have you you haven't
done home yet no home is the last show
13 December 13th yeah that's going to be
insane y yeah yeah for sure shout out to
uh for people who don't know like what
was your main reason for taking so long
to drop an album cuz it was what a 5year
Hiatus or something like that yeah like
something like that yeah um so like
right after the right after I came off
to Drake and 3 Amigos tour
like I went on like a little I want I
needed to take a break cuz Lots was
going on like I just I found out my
friend died after I went on vacation and
my management situation was crazy at
that time I had a different manager then
you see right now Stu have I have two
managers always had two managers and
he's always been around they both always
been around but my brother Banks here I
I brought him in cuzz I needed a
restructure but I didn't bring him in
until we're already a year into Co right
and he was bringing plays and I was like
oh why you bringing a lot of plays right
now we eating right now so I was like
you know what it just made me see where
I what I should do with my team so I was
like you know let me do that but it was
I just I really wanted to only take a
year off and then Co made me you know
CO's a [__] yeah so that that
just ruined everything you know I was
trying to drop the album and a lot of
push back was that the tour where Drake
was running around on the basketball
court
yeah that was the one yeah that was the
one yeah yeah yeah just I was like the
cardio Drake had on that tour had to be
crazy it was just like a giant
basketball court size stage screen thing
and you have people like come and shoot
and and they want like a prize of prize
money or something I can't remember how
much but it was a lot I remember what
was that tour like it was amazing it was
crazy I was it was crazy cuz I was
depressed the whole tour though you know
why were you like what was I the
industry and me was like it was just
clashing you know like I'm like I was
trying to like almost fit in instead of
trying to just be myself and I was kind
of just going through like a whole bunch
of phases where I was like okay so who
am I supposed to be right and yeah I was
just lost I was lost that whole tour was
that the first culture album that Migos
were toner that cult yeah it was culture
2 yeah that's when all the the crazy
hits they were performing they had some
[__] yeah that album was insane what was
it like uh like obviously for people who
don't know takeoff did you have a
relationship with him obviously being on
the road with never really spoke to a
lot of the Migos I I SP I really only
met quo okay right but um me and myself
take off knew of me yeah you know rest
in peace take cuz you opening the tour
right yeah I was opening the tour um I
remember I spoke to one of his artists
at the time we were supposed to do a
feature and then we it was just we lik
some on Instagram and the DMS or some
[__] she was just so love you know so
you know we knew of each other you know
and he knew of me but we never really
spoke but it was always like a when you
know when you show me love on the
grandma was like oh okay salute you know
like it's it's mad love what's been your
favorite city so far on the tour uh this
La show was actually like la la was
insane like good cities um we were at
the novo oh noo a VI yeah the novo was
good I did it the last tour too so a
great venue yeah man it was good it was
really good really good amazing turn I
was going to ask you uh for you man like
is it is it you know when you're signed
to OVO there's a certain level of
prestige that comes with that for you is
there ever like what are the negatives
about that obviously then all the random
Drake questions you probably get but is
there any cuz we always think like oh if
someone like Drake cosigned you there's
a lot of great that comes with it but is
there a gift and a curse of that that
like you like I mean you could say
because well he is the biggest artist in
the world like in a sense you know so
not even in a sense so like you know
what comes with like trying to it's him
or the
weekend I would it's a I feel like it's
always been a battle it's one but it's
one of them too they're both from your
city no for sure yeah I mean if I feel
like Drake's one weak and second you
know what I'm saying like it's like I
feel like it's always been like right
there but um
I mean Hey Taylor
Swift Taylor Taylor Swift bro that [__]
is selling out all kind of [__]
football stadiums she she crazy she's on
a whole different League though she's
doing movie [__] yeah number one
movie in the different numbers yeah I
know yeah she doing different numbers I
don't get the Taylor thing God bless her
I don't know I don't know a single song
bro do you like her music I mean I never
really listened to it too much but you
know cuz it never was but I know the
songs I love her songs are they slapping
Taylor Swift in Canada uh yeah of course
yeah like crazy they are they love it
yeah they love Taylor uh but you were
saying is there what is the gift and the
curse for the OVO Co yeah um I mean it
it's I feel like when you get signed to
like a big artist it's always different
compared to being signed on the label
there's a lot that you have to fight
through but I mean I found out I find
that there was a lot of benefits with me
being on the label you know just and me
being the artist that I am I'm already
so different so then already being on
the label that now being different and
people naturally like my you know sound
me being different who I am it I feel
like it just worked in my favor so there
was I never I always yeah there's always
negatives but I always look past it and
focus on those positives and just what
are the negatives I mean it was always
just trying to get around C maybe
certain barriers you know but at the end
of the day I always find a way to get
around you know if I can't go that way
I'm going to go this way you know find
my way do you uh like like how was like
the relationship with everybody on the
label because there's obviously you
maget Jordan's great they [__] fire
yeah man every everybody's good Smiley's
amazing yeah dog we're all we're all
family man you know Smiley's the
funniest guy everybody we all love
Smiley man dude he came on the show and
freestyled and it was like Smiley's
freestyle on our show like I it was very
interesting but I just me and him still
seeing it every like for real once every
few days we're like dropping lines from
his freeza he's like it's
Cody that's my dog oh I love Smiley man
what we need what is the toron like give
me some Toronto slang that we could use
if we ever go to to Toronto what is like
cuz y'all be saying some [__] I don't
understand what the [__] means you
know mandm
mm that's a okay that's a basic one
mandm just like the guys you know man oh
like man and them no no just man them
like the man's them like the man's them
you know like I'm with the manand them
yeah see it there yeah yeah there we go
yeah yeah yeah there we go yeah you know
and you know things that's that's that's
a are we calling that a Toronto thing is
that a Toronto are you guys claiming
Tings no I mean it's it's it's not just
a Toronto like I got a Ting over here
even the Toronto lingo is not even just
a Toronto Ting you know it's really it's
like a it's really a yachi Ting like a
Jamaican Caribbean influence and then UK
also has very similar even New York my
[__] New York has very similar to St no
New York has some other [__] bro what up
God yeah but I mean okay for I've seen
something the other Instagram they like
they be saying it's brick outside we say
it's brick outside too in Tonto cold
exactly yeah yeah we say brick for cold
yeah but it's a we say the same [__]
certain things are the same you know you
say fam you say fam a lot I think a lot
of people seem to think that like
Toronto is like a really sweet place but
then you know recently people have gone
there and gotten robbed yeah yeah it's
not it's not sweet as everybody very
active from what I hear in certain areas
it's it's always been the whole city is
yeah it can get popping anywhere really
doesn't matter who you are to yeah yeah
it gets popping is it like is there a
protocol if you go to Toronto do do you
have to check in no man you it's not
like that bad it's not like Detroit no
no no I listen I don't know about all of
that if you go to Detroit you got to
check in with trick trick yeah see I
don't hey I don't know man you know the
culture is different now the culture is
different compared to how it used to be
you know in the streets so yeah